there is a state of consciousness
possible in humans where you are fully
conscious without the activity of
conceptual thinking I'm Dave Rubin and
joining me on the Rubin report today is
the internationally best-selling author
of the power of now which is sold 12
million copies worldwide since it was
first published with translations into
52 languages along with his most recent
book a new earth which has already sold
over 15 million copies worldwide and has
been translated into 50 languages
Eckhart Tolle welcome to the Rubin
report thank you I am I am truly
thrilled to have you here and I suspect
this is going to be an interview like no
other that I've done do you have a
preference for what language since
you've been translated into basically
every living language on earth is
English gonna be okay for the purposes
of this I'll be happy with English I
wrote it in English I do give talks
sometimes in German and Spanish but
before I do that I was preparing myself
in a read the German and Spanish
translations of the book yeah well all
right we'll go with English at least for
the beginning portion of this so the way
that you end up here because I think
people are gonna go whoa this is this is
a little different than what's going on
in Dave's garage usually you came here
by way of seeing an interview that I did
with my my friend my mentor and really
the guy that I think is the best
interviewer of all time Larry King I
thought that would be an interesting way
of starting because that that I think is
how you got introduced to yes I've also
been a fan of Larry King for many years
and I happened to come across your
interview with him on YouTube and I was
very impressed not only by you as an
interviewer because you as you have that
openness that many interviewers lack and
that of course Larry King also has and I
was very impressed by some of the things
that Larry actually said about how he
conducts the interviews he always come
to a place of curiosity from a place of
not knowing for place of wanting to find
out the interviewees perspective
and most interviewers of course come
from a they have a mental position that
they seek to protect or they are trying
to prevail with their mental positions
they're not really interested in what
the interviewee has to say so after
seeing that interview our grief during
the interview with Larkin action
mentioned he interviewed me a few weeks
after right where I watch that interview
and that was another coincidence and
when Larry King interviewed me I
mentioned having seen your interview
with him and then our makeup artists
connected us because she works for Larry
as well as for you yeah and here we are
and here we are all right well I guess a
good way to start for the few people
watching that don't know you can you
just tell me a little bit about your
background and until you were 29 years
old
spirituality actually wasn't wasn't your
thing people are so associated of that
with you but can you tell a little bit
about growing up yes I grew up in
Germany out to the age of 15 at 15 I
left school I just couldn't stand it
anymore so I refused to go to school my
parents had gotten a divorce my dad had
moved to Spain and my mom didn't know
what to do with me I was just hanging
around at home didn't want us to go to
school anymore so I was saying to live
with my dad in Spain where I lived for
four years to the age of 19 without
going to school my dad was always a very
unconventional person and he asked me do
you want to go to school I said no and
then he said well and don't Wow so what
were you doing I pursued my own
interests I read some food started
reading literature of course learning
Spanish learning English I loved
languages I loved reading enough
literature at 16 I started working
part-time as a translator of restaurant
menus and then I became a to igano 17 I
became a tour guide for taking people
around from cruise ships around Spanish
town where we lived and then at 19 I
moved to England to work in England I
was immediately I they immediately felt
at home I have to feel some deep
connection with England and I worked in
England for four years full time and
became a more interested in intellectual
things so I took all the necessary exams
that were required to get into
University the cold there were at the
time they were called all levels in a
levels and so on so I took those exams
and finally I got a scholarship to get
into a London University where I studied
modern languages and literature and so
that's the external story on the inside
I experienced increasingly periods of
terrible anxiety and depression even
Bala while I was working and while I was
a student can you describe what that was
- yes it was an inability to stop my
mind my mind was continuously racing
along and creating scenarios of where I
failed where I lost even a little that I
had it went a lot into the past to where
I felt ashamed about things that happen
in the past but not only that there was
a deeper existential fear an existential
anguish that's how to describe it it is
a kind of alienation
the world alien invasion is probably the
best word where everything that you come
into contact with feels strange and
alien you're disconnected from
everything and everybody and that is
something that I believe many people
these days suffer from although it has
also existed it has happened to isolated
individuals in the past if you want to
read about that state I recommend in the
Old Testament there is the book of
Ecclesiastes which starts with a famous
phrase as in the old translation vanity
of vanities all is vanity but what it
really means if you use the modern term
I would translate it as everything is so
effing pointless and what's the point of
it all so that to be deeply affected by
the seeming meaninglessness of life
around you so I remember when I went
into a department store in London or
walked along the streets it's it seemed
so so absurd that people were buying all
these things and then going out with
their shopping bags full of stuff
everything seemed so absurd and
meaningless almost producing a kind of
nausea and that gnosis actually a novel
by jean-paul Sartre where he describes
that state mm-hmm
so that's exactly how it is
it's it is described in various places
in world literature too for example in
Anna Karenina at the end of the book
just before she commits suicide the
world
Tolstoy describes how she sees the world
just before she commits suicide and
everything is just every human being she
sees is despicable and dreadful and in
total disconnection from the world
around her so that is the existential
anguish that
I also experience quite frequently did
you have a sort of rock bottom moment
with that was there a specific moment
that then started your turnaround yes
so I would often wake up in the middle
of the night in the state of panic or
fear and almost feeling breathless and
one night I woke up again on three in
the morning and my mind was racing along
and then a strange thought came into my
mind that said I can't live with myself
any longer I can't live with myself any
longer and after thinking that thought
there was a kind of this little shift
occurred I was standing back from that
thought so to speak and it's not what a
strange thought to think I can't live
with myself and my one Who am I - who is
that self that I cannot live with and
Who am I so a kind of inner separation
occurred and I felt like of disappearing
into a kind of void and the next morning
I awoke woke up and I felt incredibly
peaceful for some reason I didn't
understand why it took me several years
to understand why from that point onward
there was always in sometimes in the
foreground sometimes in the background
the sense of inner peace no matter what
my outer circumstances were but now I
can exactly explain what happened that
night there was a dis identification in
my consciousness from the stream of
compulsive and incessant thinking that
most people have absolutely no control
over people say I think but that is
usually not the case because thinking
happens to them they have no control
over it
so it is actually wrong to say I think
it would be same as you were saying I'm
beating my heart you're not beating
heart it's done for you it happens to
you yeah
so there was this
now called the voice in the head that I
was completely identified with so I was
completely identified with the stream of
thinking that which is quite normal many
people are and a lot of that stream of
thinking was of a negative nature so I
did not experience the reality around me
except through the veil of negative
self-talk the veil the mental veil of
negatives of negative labeling and
interpretations and I my whole what I
consider to be my life I hadn't realized
until I decide enta fide what I took to
be my life was a narrative in my mind
and it consisted of certain things in
the past that I identified with things
that had happened to me it was a bundle
of thoughts that record continuously
that gave me my sense of self and it was
an unhappy sense of self
it was a narrative based sense of self
and that night I stood back from this
narrative which is fueled by continuous
thinking I stood back and I realized for
the first time it I mentioned of
consciousness within myself that was
deeper funk roots also say higher
depends how you want to look at it
deeper than thinking now this dimension
of consciousness that's deeper than
thinking I now call it awareness or
sometimes call it presence and that
exists in every human being but most
humans are not aware of it at all they
don't know that there is a deeper
dimension of consciousness in them and
that I mentioned is transcends thinking
it you experience it when the mind
becomes still for a moment this is what
people want to achieve for example when
they meditate it can also happen to you
when you engage
in a dangerous activity like mountain
climbing well then you cannot be
involved in thinking you have to kill
conceptual thinking stops but you do not
lose consciousness so the important
thing is there is a state of
consciousness possible in humans where
you are fully conscious without the
activity of conceptual thinking that's
also the essence for example of Zen and
I would suggest that it's actually the
essence of all spirituality is to find
that state of consciousness in yourself
where you can be alert and aware but you
there's no conceptualization in your
mind it doesn't mean it stays like that
for a long time you then go back into
thinking but if you're able to access
that I mentioned in yourself you are no
longer possessed by your thinking mind
you are no longer used by your thinking
mind you are actually able to use your
mind instead of being used by your mind
as long as you are used by your mind all
your mental activity is a reflection of
the conditioning that has happened to
you so you take on the conditioning from
a personal on a personal level from
school
parental background and so in that
conditions the way that you think then
you have the collective conditioning
around you you take on the conditioning
of the the culture that you in inhabit
that's around you if you if you watch
the media every day then you take on
those viewpoints and that you think they
are your thoughts
they're not your thoughts you take these
thoughts on from the outside and they
become part of your identity so identity
is a key word because identity everybody
is extremely interested and in finding
their identity one could say that after
after meeting the
needs of food and shelter almost
immediately after let's come to search
for an identity which already starts
with a child when the child has a toy
that feels it belongs to me it's my toy
somebody takes it away there's great
suffering in the child it cries because
the child began to identify with
something and called it mine and that's
only the beginning of course so please
yeah there well there's so many there's
so many things that I that I want to
jump into so well I guess first we are
gonna get to some of the techniques that
you you know so that many other people
use to to attain this sort of level of
peace and separation from that that's
sort of endless stream but do you think
that most people whether they're
conscious of it or not are just all day
long just sort of spinning like a top
out of control where they they bounce in
and out of this at all time so you might
do all sorts of things during the day
that are distractions and you can get
upset about politics or do drugs or
waste time with this or that but then we
all have that voice in us that that sort
of knows more of the right way to do
things or more of a peaceful way to do
things but we but we don't have any way
to really I don't know it's controlled
the right word I don't know if control
is the right word but we don't have any
way to really ascertain what's really
happening yes unless you're you are
completely neurotic or or even
clinically insane you probably have some
access I'm not talking to you instantly
you can diagnose me at the end if you're
not if you're not continuously in a
state of confusion or anxiety or
depression if you're not if you
occasionally you feel okay you feel
occasionally happy you probably have
some access to that I mentioned in
yourself without knowing it without
recognizing it so there are actually we
could describe this as moments in your
daily life
brief moments when you're actually not
thinking but they're very they tend to
be for most people very brief but
they're very significant these are
moments perhaps you are looking at
something and you're looking you might
be looking at a tree or flower or the
sky and for a moment there's three
seconds when you take this in completely
often it's something natural that you're
looking at and you're looking at the sky
and perhaps for the first three or four
seconds we are looking at it you feel a
sense of inner expansion almost like
coming to a to rest and then perhaps
after four five six seconds the mind
comes in and interprets what you have
just seen I also find that people find
enter that state without knowing it when
they relate to pets or to animals when
you meet a dog you look into the eyes of
the dog now the dog is a conscious being
but the dog has no conceptual thinking
so when you look into the eyes of the
dog you instinctively realize that the
dog is not judging you in any way
because they dog had no concepts by
which to judge you so you feel kind of
when you look into the eyes of the doc
you feel a moment of liberation from
your comb your conceptual self because
there you have a being who has no
conceptual self so you're able to feel
what so to speak the beingness the being
of the dog and that's and in that moment
you're not thinking a few seconds of
inner spaciousness and then it feels
good to be with this animal I call dogs
guardians of being and and so another
one is look into the eyes of a bunny old
baby when this baby is looking back at
you and this baby has not yet arrived at
conceptualization but there is obviously
a luminous consciousness there and the
eyes of the baby can be just amazing
when the baby looks at you like this
mm-hmm and you feel wow this touches you
deeply in that moment you are free of
concepts or thing
because the baby's not thinking
conceptually and you're connecting with
this beautiful being at a deeper level
so there are moments when you are
naturally free of the stream of thinking
and those are the most worthwhile
moments in your life ultimately it could
happen also when you're out in nature
you're hiking or you're you're doing
some physical activity and you're not
thinking very much you're taking it or
the world it surrounds you their sense
of sensory perception you're taking
everything in
you're completely present when you're in
the forest or or the mountain on the
beach you're completely present and
suddenly you feel so peaceful why do you
feel so peaceful do you feel so peaceful
because you are out in nature well the
indirectly yes but the real reason why
you feel so peaceful is that in that
moments you are conscious and
consciously perceiving but not thinking
do you think what do you think one way
to describe it in sort of simplistic
terms would be that when you're doing
sort of what you're supposed to be doing
that you can lock into that kind of
thinking because I can give you two
quick examples from myself I've had a
few moments in the hundreds of
interviews that I've done where there's
something where I can lock eyes with
someone and we are so right here doing
exactly where we're supposed to be doing
what we're supposed to be doing that
actually some of the background almost
gets a little bit blurry I I can feel I
mean I can feel a little bit of it right
now actually there's and you can't you
can't hold it it just it comes and goes
and all those things so I've had it in
this very room and then the other time
that I think I've had it was when I was
doing stand-up and there was one
particular night where I was killing I
mean I had the room in my hand and I
remember seeing myself from behind
myself it was actually I could actually
see the back of myself and I don't even
remember what I was saying but it almost
was like slow-motion it was like yes
this is what I was supposed to be doing
is that is that a good way to yes that
can happen when you're engaged in an
activity and certainly you're guided by
an intelligence there
is greater than the collected
information that you have in your minds
now that intelligence that cut is I call
it the unconditioned consciousness
whereas the mind is the conditioned
consciousness that intelligence can use
your mind and then your mind becomes a
creative tool so and then you can be
spontaneous in for example in your
presentation when you're on stage and
you will come up with things that you
could never have thought lived if they
they come because you're concerned
connected with a deeper level of
consciousness within yourself and that
ultimately is the way to live as much as
nobody is connected a hundred percent of
the time with that but to be connected
with that when you're engaged in your
whatever your main activity is that's a
it's an act of grace if you're able to
do that and then you are empowered
whatever you do is empowered by
something much greater than yourself and
what is that it is I say you have access
to what I call it sounds perhaps a
little bit mystical universal
intelligence of which the human mind is
only one expression there are countless
expressions of universal intelligence
and all spirit all the ancient spiritual
teachings they actually point that way
Mayock if I if you don't mind if I may
interpret some interpret something that
Jesus said between I believe is actually
exactly the same thing Jesus often talks
about the Kingdom of Heaven interesting
expression and I there's a line which I
opened the Bible the other day and I saw
the line said Jesus went from village to
village and from town to town and said
repent for the kingdom of heaven is at
hand and the the whole thing is already
contained there repent means it's miss
it's a mistranslation repentance the
original Greek is Metanoia which means a
turnaround is shift a couple
saved so the repentance what do people
think of it as apologize or something
like that yes we do yourself up I'm such
a miserable sinner
that's not let's a missing the
misinterpretation of repentance started
when it was translated into Latin into
the latinus many 10 Thea which was
already wrong and now we have Metanoia
as repentance no a complete reverse a
complete turnaround in other words a
shift in consciousness repent now what
does he mean by the Kingdom of Heaven
now Christians
traditionally believed it's something
it's going to come let's the belief they
completely overlooked when they asked
Jesus when when does the kingdom of
heaven come he said the kingdom of
heaven does not come with observation in
another translation it says the kingdom
of heaven does not come with signs to be
perceived you cannot say it's over here
boy it's over there
for the kingdom of heaven is within you
now what is that thing that's within you
where you can never say it's there or
it's there I I retracted kingdom of
heaven into modern terminology for
kingdom i would substitute dimension in
heaven what is heaven when you look up
into heaven you see the vast sky the
spaciousness of the sky he used that
analogy to point us to an inner reality
he is used because of the language
usually refers to external things that
you can see in touch so the closest that
Jesus could find in the external world
to point to something in the inner realm
was to look at the vast spaciousness of
the sky which in itself has no
particular form but it's amazing and he
said the kingdom of heaven then is
heaven my translation is spaciousness in
a spaciousness which is the uncluttered
mind consciousness without concepts work
without thought inner alert stillness
the dimension of spaciousness find that
I mention of that the primordial
teaching in Jesus find that within
yourself find the kingdom of heaven find
the dimension of inner spaciousness
where you're able to be alert and still
completely conscious but not thinking
and that's the essence of Jesus teaching
to find that when you find that then you
right when you really relate to other
human beings you can sense the same
dimension in the other human although
they have a personality which is a
conditioned self but underneath so to
speak the personality there is a deeper
being and the deeper being is their
unconditioned consciousness but it's
don't consciousness is not a personal
thing
so when I look at you first thing I
would see is your personality and of
course the physical body and the
personality whatever makes up your
personality but if I look more deeply
and not just look but actually sense
your presence I know that beyond your
personality there's an essence in you
that it is one with the essence in me
and one could you describe it as
consciousness itself the essence of who
you are the essence of Who I am is
consciousness when I recognize that
consciousness the same consciousness
that in me this consciousness beyond the
condition itself recognizes the
consciousness in you that which is
beyond your conditioned self and that
recognition is what Jesus called love
and therefore he said love thy neighbor
as thyself
but that as a separate statement it
doesn't work but when you put it
together with Kingdom of Heaven that
reads find the Kingdom of Heaven within
you the dimension of spaciousness then
you will recognize your neighbor which
is anybody buddy that you are with then
you will recognize him aha
as yourself and this recognition that in
essence you are one that you are deeply
deeply connected that you share the
Concord the one consciousness when you
recognize them in the other then you
have suddenly an outlaw of benevolence
and goodwill and love not the ego love
but true love towards the witch in the
Old Testament in the New Testaments
agape spiritual love for another human
being you can sense a very beingness so
and that's the whole secret of the
growth of all spirituality it's in Jesus
in the teaching of Jesus it is so the
the our purpose here beyond the personal
purposes that we have everybody has
their personal purpose the work you do
whatever it is there's a deeper purpose
that the personal purpose must be
aligned with and that deeper purpose is
to live from that deeper place the way I
interpret you know in the English
language doesn't have a word that
describes both men and women it's the
German language has mensch
which is also used in Girish to the
german wa s mensch means both man or
woman for a long time I regret it that
the English language doesn't have a word
for human you have to say human being
but now I'm happy that I have to say
human being because that describes
exactly the two dimensions the human is
a conditioned self it's a personality
your historical person just comes from
the past based on past who you are as a
person they could includes your physical
body and your psychological self I
called it sometimes your form identity
there's a physical form and there's a
psychological form of you that's the
human and then there's a being the being
is the deeper self that is consciousness
unconditioned and no human life is
fulfilled unless the human has at least
some access
to this dimension within them that
really is the ultimate purpose to at
least maybe not complete access but at
least you have glimpses of that which
transcends the self to have glimpses of
self transcendence in your life if you
no matter how successful you are in this
world if you have never had even a
glimpse of self transcendence then your
life is pretty purposeless and and it's
very unlikely that you will be a happy
human being is the ultimate paradox with
all of this that it's almost impossible
to hold on to so even someone that has
spent their life trying to attain that
state that you can't hey you can't you
to function as a human maybe not as a
human being but just as a human it would
be almost impossible to constantly be
yes that state in a world that doesn't
exist in that state
yes not constantly but it is possible to
to eat to not just have that when you
are perhaps they say engaged in
spiritual practice or you're meditating
or when you're out in nature and some
happy moments out in nature it it is our
task to as much as possible incorporate
that deeper level of consciousness into
our daily life even if we don't succeed
all the time that's fine that's part of
the practice so one could say then our
purpose in our daily life beyond the
personal purpose which is also important
because we need to honor who we are as a
person too and we need to honor our
identity as a person because not out
italy that exists and whatever it is
that makes up your identity whether it's
mostly personal kind whether you
identify with a concern a collective
around you it could be your religion
income whatever it might be or the
culture that you grow up in that has its
place that that's nothing wrong with it
but if that is all you know about
yourself that's very limiting
so you honor it but there's more to you
than that and that's why the ancient
Greeks said starting from Pythagoras 500
BC know thyself the most perhaps the
most important dictum in ancient Greek
philosophy which was carved craft on the
walls of the temple of apollo at delphi
know thyself very deep saying know who
you are
in your essence so because you have the
form identity which is a personality the
form and you hasn't have as i call it an
essence identity and so to know yourself
as this essence is it called in in in
indian some in some Indian Indian
spiritual philosophy it's called
self-realization so you know and and
then the practice becomes in daily life
to as much as possible live from that
dimension for example now that countless
examples one could give very simple
things like I recommend for example
whenever you are waiting for something
at the elevator or you're in the
elevator or you're waiting for phone
call or you're waiting in line somewhere
the airport you're waiting this look
quite a bit of time we spent waiting
traffic lights in waiting now these days
mostly people get out their phone when
they are waiting because this means
there's a continued continuously your
mind is being cluttered more and more I
call it clutter clutter it's useless
information they get often they get out
their phone they don't know why they get
out their phone because it's probably
next to them is getting out their phone
and then they start switching your are
hmm
that's there would be a moment whenever
you're waiting an opportunity to in that
moment to declutter your mind and create
a little bit of inner spaciousness the
kingdom of heaven the dimension of
spaciousness
for example this is very ancient and
very simple method by becoming aware
that you are breathing you're becoming
it I call it it's a mini meditation one
conscious press which is the embrace and
you follow the breast with your
attention you feel it the air moving
into the body you might even feel it
into your evening to your abdomen the
energy and then you breathe out one and
what does that do why is it so important
when you're aware of your breathing you
take attention away from thinking you
cannot be completely aware of your
breathing and think at the same time you
can either think or be aware of your
breathing so that's a quick way of
having a little bit of spaciousness in
your life one conscious bus maybe -
conscious breaths everybody has time for
one or two conscious press from time to
time during the day nobody is so busy
that this guy cannot take six seven or
eight seconds for contra call of the
mind might tell you know too much to do
it's a lie don't believe every thought
that comes into your head and then you
create spaciousness the more spacious
and recreate the more effect if your
thinking will be when you start thinking
again because then thinking can link
into this creative intelligence that is
the unconditioned intelligence in you
and then it can be inspired by that I
would select every creative person who
create something really new had some
access to that dimension in in the area
of their creative endeavor probably not
in the rest of their lives if I require
what could as crazy as everybody else
for the rest of their lives but when
they engage in their act of creation
they have access to that dimension and
that's so this is once you you touch
this power within you which is not egoic
power it's not power over somebody else
it's primordial the power of life itself
when you can sense that within yourself
that becomes the basis for your sense of
you are no longer the story in your mind
and that's the shift so you become free
of identity having to completely
identify with your past arrive
occurrences we are from your historical
past which is most people's past it's
just a very mixed back and there's a lot
of it you may not like instead of that
your sense of who we are comes from a
deeper place and that resolves all
questions of what people are concerned
with self-esteem self-confidence people
go to therapists you build up their
self-esteem because it's not kind of but
once you touch that level of
consciousness within yourself
self-esteem comes from there but it's
not comparative anymore then you can
sense the power that dwells within you
and you don't need to compare yourself
to somebody else and say I'm powerful
because I have more than this person you
know in essence every human has that but
they mostly don't know it but it's there
as a seat one could say in every human
being it's just it's so wonderful this
realization
[Music]